don't play with nature if things happen
be accountable you're grown that's
absolutely have accountability and then
they'll what up guys welcome to the just
pearly things youtube channel today i
have a special guest on the channel hey
guys i'm back it's miriam hope you're
well so today you're going to be
introduced to rolo tomasu
so this is something very new to me rolo
tomasi is like the king of the
manosphere okay he is probably the most
educated in terms of stats fact like he
he has a study for everything like fats
and biggest yes yes and he wrote books
called the rational male that talk about
like the true nature of women ah
interesting and for example like a lot
of men put women on a pedestal and think
they're above like doing like ratchet
ass like fatty ass things
down the street they're down they're
down
and so stuff like that he goes on this
podcast and just give you a little bit
of uh background this is coco i did a
podcast with her too actually okay she's
32 okay and she's very much in the like
why men love [ __ ] type of like the
the same book i was telling you about
and yeah rolo's on here the medium is
the message is she flaking on you for
dates that's the message is she is she
uh you know uh sort of in
indecisive about being with you is she
making you jump through hoops
women break rules for alpha males and
they make more rules for beta males is
she making you rules if that's the case
then you're probably her attraction to
your interest in you is probably not
what it ought to be because women will
break rules to get with a guy who is so
high value because women understand that
they can't afford to miss out on that
opportunity with a guy who's a high
value guy so they will tend to break
rules for that guy and make rules for
guys like you're saying before here
where it's like
they'll try to cover it up with love
right or they'll try to cover up the
lack of like being hot for that guy with
other things guys will do exactly the
same thing too they'll try to convince
themselves that she's really into it but
she's really not into it and i said is
she making rules for you that's number
one if you want to you want one sort of
litmus test for your dating is she
making rules for you or is she breaking
rules for you because she really wants
to get with you and she has this really
just hot desire for you and then i think
probably the the third most common is
how do i get my wife to have sex with me
again wow
how do i how do i get her how do i get
her back you know they most of the guys
who i deal with who are older and they
are married that's their their their
primary concern because they you they
think that they used to be able to have
sex with her and maybe it's true
when they were single and then they got
married and she turned the sex spigot
off can i uh what do you think of that
interesting
i think interesting i'm sat here like so
cause think of this right yeah girls if
they like a guy he doesn't have to do
[ __ ] yeah 100 he doesn't have to do [ __ ]
like he doesn't have to take them on
dates they'll they'll have all these
like high standards until they like a
guy right yeah and i think even like
what i think of guys i've dated like
there's one guy that had to do less
because i was just super into him yeah
and like and there's other guys that
like did did more right and it's like i
think a lot of guys don't realize that
yeah i think they don't realize that
when you first get with somebody or you
decide that you're gonna start dating
somebody a woman will subconsciously or
consciously depending on how people are
will weigh out her options and be like
okay these are the pros these are the
cottons do the pros outweigh the cons or
is it that one con that's kind of
holding me back
off of the back of that that's how woman
now knows how to move whether she'll
make you work 10 times harder whether
she'll
let you ease off a little bit and just
want to be with you and want to enjoy
her time with you it's very much
tailored to what a woman wants for
herself you know well i think but he's
saying basically that don't deal with
the women that are constantly making
rules for you because they don't like
you and they don't want you yeah yeah
they just don't want you like whatever
whatever prose you have for them makes
sense for them at that moment in time so
they'll keep you around but whether it's
a physical attraction or there's
personality or mentality things that
they don't like they don't want you
they're going to keep you and arms down
from a female person i'm not married
obviously but i speak to a lot of women
also
like about marriage and lack of sex and
i have a lot of men also messaging me
asking all those 13
so they what i think is in the beginning
when you were dating your person you
were doing a lot you were taking her on
the dates and you were doing this and
maybe you both were more fit or you were
hotter or whatever like everything was
just more exciting now sex became like a
chore and guys don't like he's not gonna
you know give you a little sexy massage
and you're not gonna put your he's gonna
come to you and bet you're gonna be like
oh you wanna [ __ ] you wanna do it that's
what men do nowadays i got half an hour
and that's i gotta fix this quick honey
i gotta fold laundry so you you finish
up and that's what happens in marriages
now it does it's not it's not special
anymore it's like just like you said oh
let's do this now so we can do the
laundry later and you're not into it and
i feel
it's both sides is that just inevitable
in every relationship is that like i
think so number oh really if you make it
like that yeah then it is but it's it
you should work on your sex life the
same way you work on your like
day-to-day things
do you think sex is a duty in marriage
yes yeah i think yeah i think it's about
maintaining
and yeah i think it's about maintaining
the relationship and i think sex is a
big part of that like any form of
affection sexual pleasure anything like
that that is a requirement and i think
it's a requirement both ways and i think
it's important that's acknowledged
because when a man or woman is not happy
with what's going on in their sex life
it translates into everything else
within your relationship and now your
relationship's crumbling because you
don't want to focus on that a little
more you know i said i got a lot of heat
on tick tock be sick because
i'm actually banned for three days no
way you guys
i'm so tired of these people reporting
me
um but but i got flack because i said i
don't think cheating's black and white
what i meant was i think it's wrong
right i don't agree with cheating but if
you're starving a man of sex i don't
think you can be mad if he goes
elsewhere if you haven't slept with your
husband in two years and he cheats i
don't think it's necessarily that he
doesn't love you yeah but like men have
urges and i think that's you're putting
your husband in a really bad position
if you're not sleeping with him i agree
i think i think
a lot of women feel
sex is powerful women are powerful we
need to really like understand how much
power a woman can possess with her
sexual side of things and her sexual
being when you remove that from a
romantic relationship what's left yeah
you're just roommates you're friends
yeah or you're like really good friends
whether you like it on a he he might
love you care for you whatever and vice
versa but there's no sexual relationship
there which takes it out of a marriage
or or any form of relationship and with
i've never really agreed with with
withholding sex maybe you have an
argument and that night you're like babe
i'm not no yeah like that's cool but to
withhold sex for a year two years three
years like stepping out of your marriage
will forever be wrong because you've
blessed it you've made a union in front
of god or whatever else it may be but
what did you expect you know what i mean
you're not sleeping with him someone
asked me so and especially if he's
coming home happy and not bothered like
you should be questioning if you've
withheld sex from your man and he's not
said anything about it yeah
well it's a bad deal for men though
because it's like like the our mating
strategies to get resources yeah like we
tell like protection and resources their
mating strategy is to screw as many
women as possible right and we both make
a compromise when we come into a
marriage right because we say you know
what i'm not gonna hop to the like next
most successful guy to keep you know
yeah and they say you know what i'm not
gonna screw every girl and you're both
compromising your mating strategy but
it's like you're not giving him his end
of the deal you're getting the
protection and the resources but you're
not giving up the sex and that's
important because women single women do
the most to move up the food chain right
and single men are breeders they spread
their seed so when you've made that
commitment to become a union and
eradicate that for the sake of the other
person certain things really need to be
evaluated like you can't just withhold
sex so you can't just you know it's like
it's like if if a man just quit his job
and decided he wants to stay at home
and you're not going to be happy with
that you're going to be thinking well
who's going to be paying for bills yeah
who's going to be doing x y and z said
like you need to both be on the same i'm
a big believer and leave the whales and
the bums
like i feel like if your dude refuses to
work yeah leave his ass
but if she refuses to get on the
treadmill leave her ass yeah i guess i'm
not saying if you bought her at one size
you can't expect her yeah that's what
you bought her yeah yeah but she's 120
and now she's 220 what the [ __ ] what are
you doing yeah yeah yeah unless it's
like post-pregnancy and you've like just
come out of it cool yeah give her give
her a couple months after the kids i
would say give her a year like during
that year to start working out and do
her thing my mom had seven kids
yeah yeah y'all see her on the channel
she does not all these we are not
healthy
speaking of sex life i want to bring up
this and then we're going to get to the
celebrity stuff uh the sexual market
value we've spoken about this at length
are you familiar with this sexual market
value
exactly
so
would you break down sexual market value
so let me ask you a question first of
all we'll get to rollo
would you say that you're at your peak
sexual market value right now at age 30
31
i think that i'm the best now that i've
been before okay i'm the best whatever
the grammar is not my side i'm the best
i could be right now i am you're the
best version of yourself right now yes
um
what age do you want to get married by
i don't really care
i i mean marriage for me is not like
oh by 30 i have i already passed it like
it's by 40.
it's yeah i would like to get married by
40. but by 50 how high of a priority is
it for you right now
it's not really such a hybrid what about
kids what age would you like to have
kids do you want to have kids i want to
have kids i want to have kids by
i don't know 35
okay i i'm gonna i'm gonna give you a
case example and then i want to open up
the sexual market value there was a girl
that i used to like just be friends with
we kind of like were you know like dated
in high school whatever not dated but
like i actually kind of wanted her more
than she wanted me and it was like
whatever never happened
we went to a party it was a 40th
birthday party last year okay
i'm single i had some serious
relationships i was single
making money life's good
you know she's still single 40.
the reception for the the difference
between us was
palatable yo adam what up 40 single
making money kill you're the man bro
oh i'll say i won't say her name
are you okay is everything
and that's what happens so that's my
point a 40 year old man
successful single no wife no kids
you're [ __ ] pimp bro
woman 40 no wife no husband no kids
people look at that as being like
you okay
like everything i know you're gonna be
all right you're not gonna kill yourself
are you yeah what are your thoughts on
that as being a beautiful high
maintenance 31 year old woman i doubt
you want to be that 40 year old you're a
40 year old woman 10 years ago yeah i
mean i think that's just the society
today and i that's i would love that to
change i just don't know when it will or
what needs to happen for this to change
but i feel
a lot of women and also that's a
question i get often it's like i like
this guy like i want to get married i'm
not sure if he's the one but i've been
with him for seven years now and i don't
want to start over and blah blah and
that
women have this pressure when they're in
their 30s or late 20s that they need to
get married and then they do get married
to this guy who they've been dating for
the past three years and then they get
married and then they realize three
years in they're miserable and then they
get a divorce and then you're
starting again so instead of rushing
into marriage because your clock is
ticking
there's no clock ticking besides like
you're you can freeze your eggs do
whatever like i don't you can do it but
there is a clock ticking though they're
women more than men i don't think
there's any okay you guys can you agree
what do you think
is there a clock ticking yeah girl
there's a biological clock you can't
what like what do you mean what do you
mean what do you mean it's like delusion
yeah like what do you actually mean
even even just your looks like i'm sorry
i was hotter at 18.
what like what are you talking about
like how is there no biological and like
but then people i think people say that
that have the money to go do ivf or get
a surrogate or whatever it may be like
they'll be like well there's no
biological clock because i couldn't go
and do x y and i said yeah there's other
options but your personal biological
clock is a real thing well is that how
you want to do it you don't want to
carry your own child you know what i
mean it's not really the optimal
solution i don't know like i feel like
there's something special about carrying
your own kid that you really can't
and i know i know some people like don't
get the opportunity to do that yeah they
can't have kids but like they would kill
for it exactly and it's like exactly and
it's like girls like this are just like
oh i'll get married whenever when i
think it's a little insensitive i think
what you want personally is is
completely up to you do you know what i
mean have your own goals and your
desires but like you said like there's
plenty women that have you know chronic
illnesses have cancers have certain
diseases where they can't have kids they
can't carry their own child they
literally can't produce eggs and they
would die to do that yeah and we have
women out here that are just flocking
the fact that
well i you know i don't i don't want to
yeah i got time i don't want to do it
myself i can get someone else to carry
my like go but how old are you i'm 21.
you're 20. okay so you're like baby i'm
a baby in the game honey uh
when do you want to be married by 23 23.
i wanted to be married like
i wish um i wish i like prioritized that
a little bit younger but i didn't really
know how i think yeah but when i was um
like i think it's better to get married
younger yeah i'd rather get married
sooner rather than later you know what
it's really funny because i never saw
myself
getting married until maybe 30 31
and then i just i just i remember
sitting with myself and thinking
realistically i want to be able to have
to have my kid before i'm 26 27 like
anything between 25 and 28 for me if my
first kid would be perfect
and then you know my second kid end of
that tale whatever
and i think it's important to like
establish that get married
live with your partner explore get to
know each other live young have that
bond young and like i agree because it
really solidifies
a lot of things in your later years and
when you get married older you're both
individuals they're both quite real in
your ways and yeah
and your mentality is very set like it's
more difficult to learn what are you
going to change at 40 about yourself
like you've been doing the same [ __ ] for
40 years no i mean what compromises are
you gonna make yeah how are you going to
blend and make a family like it's
difficult yeah yeah click i agree
there is a there is most definitely a
clock ticking so you don't think there
is an expiration date put it that way
explain that all right so you're saying
women are like so let
god hate that
i really hate people have used that
before right now it's like wine no
yeah we'll we'll get to that so so i'm
before i launch into what i'm going to
say here let me explain the debt we're
going to have to make a distinction
between sexual market value and personal
worth okay because women tend to
conflate those two
so if i say well you know you're
successful you got a you got a career
you went to college you make a hundred
thousand dollars a year blah blah blah
where's my man how come i don't have a
man right now well the reason is is
because you've turned yourself into the
man that you wanted to marry that's why
so what happens is we we sort of sell
women this bill of goods that they need
to follow sort of this masculine alpha
male uh um
life plan and then they get to 35 36
years old and they go where's where's
the guy where's where's the guy that i'm
supposed to be with well it's because as
things track the thing is that men and
women find different things attractive
in the other in the opposite sex women
believe that men should find things
attractive about them that men would
naturally or women would naturally find
attractive in a man so when we're
looking at between the ages of 18 and
about 28 years old you'll hear people
talk about this online all the time
that's the whole phase right that's the
party years
the whole phase 18 oh you know it come
on coco 18 to 28 years i would say 18 to
24. if in my experience all right well
the reason i rounded off to the 28 is
because 29 30 31 is the epiphany phase
and i'll talk about that here i agree
with that
yeah so
i know
she just
i know i know what you're going to say
too because i i did read that one post
you had on instagram i have so over a
thousand so
if you have read my work that i have the
infamous graph i think i i showed it
when i was actually patrick's show um so
at the at the at the peak levels women
at sexual market value peak years is
about 23 years old and that's when women
are the most fertile that's when they
can have children the easiest that's
when they are at the peak of fertility
they're you you're smart
[Applause]
that is the year that is the age at
which every guy from 15 all the way to
95
pegs as the most attractive that women
are
and this interesting chart so this is
like the age and this is when men and
women are at their peak of sexual market
value would you date an older guy yeah
like 35 at my age now yeah
if you look good
maybe because i think if i was you had
to like date again from 21 i would date
older i've always dated older yeah i've
dated 10 years older and i've always
always kept at 10 to 11 years old yeah
yeah um see when i was 21 i wasn't even
looking like i was like
but i think it's a good like strategy
because those guys are like
more ready to settle down exactly yeah
like you know what actually it's
something that my mom said she didn't
say go and don't date people that are 10
20 years older than you but she said
date someone that's a little bit older
because
when it comes to marriage and having
kids they're ready like you don't have
to wait around for them to mature you
have to like go through all these things
that the men have to go through they'll
be ready they'll have things sorted and
you can just slide and build your life
and i always remember her saying that i
was like yeah you're right mommy you're
right yeah she did that 23. at 23
between 22 and 24 so i you know average
it out to 23. i barely knew how to brush
my hair when i was 22.
stop it yeah
i don't you know what honestly when i'm
looking at my and i'm talking strictly
physical right now when i look at my
photos 20 21 2 3.
i'm so much hotter right now
like i'm just i just know how to like
this is delusion yeah there's and and
like honestly i think most girls speak
at like 18. they do have yeah because
most girls are the thinnest yeah and
then they like gain weight when they're
older like i would say i was my most
attractive when i was like 19 or 20.
yeah which and and i think like it
wasn't that big of a difference from
like 19 to 21 like i looked i looked the
same but it would be delusional to think
that we look the same the older we get
yeah like look better yeah no no no
honey we age yeah and you can just see
it in like people's faces like youth is
like you can't buy that you can't botox
it because we can't see it yes you can't
make that happen honey it's just natural
like does it like come on you're telling
me
she's like she's probably one to ten
she's actually better looking in person
this lighting doesn't do her well i'd
say when she was younger she's probably
like like an eight when she was younger
and i i say eight is like
you could get a modeling cut like
prettiest person is small town that's
how i describe eight sixes are like cute
i'd say she's like a five now five six
oh god
but the thing is most people are fives
like this is the scale yeah yeah this
scale is like like
it sounds harsh but like to to
to give you context like i give myself a
five five six like cuz five six is like
pretty cute yeah eight to ten is like
you could model like that's how like
symmetrical your face is until at one
point she probably could have modeled
but like you'd lose like two points by
the time you hit 30.
you do it's not it's not fun yeah it's
just there's some people that get away
with it like sierra how you think like
yeah some some [ __ ] get away with
that yes they do i'd say black girls get
an extra like five years yes because
they just age better but like it just is
what it is and this is delusion
i know how to do my hair i know how to
do my makeup you should probably get
like a comparison there and take a poll
feel free
to find it on my eyes
well
i'm glad you have high self-esteem let's
just start start right there but anyways
between 18 and 12.
they'll say it's the whole face i didn't
make the word they did um but i call it
the party years in my second book and
that's usually at the time where women
have the most sexual capital that's when
they get the million dollar if in sexual
agency that's when they're handed here's
a million dollar check and you've got to
make a good investment remember we were
talking about finding a guy who's a good
bet for the future the reason women get
so like gary vee's you know wife
that he's divorcing is so pissed off or
that this is a trophy wife is because
she's taken some of that sexual capital
and she's put it into gary so what
happens is it represents an opportunity
cost or a loss was it a
a loss of investment if he doesn't pay
off if it doesn't pay dividends when her
sexual market value decays when she's in
her 30s and her 40s and now he's worth
way more because men's sexual market
value tends to peak right around 35 36
37 years old because that's the point at
which men have the most potential i
didn't say they're all going to do this
but they made lawyer in the law firm
they you know they're they've made the
surgeon their whatever it is they built
themselves up to have the most of what
women find most attractive in a man the
status is right around that time and of
course and as i said before this uh
success objects whatever he still has to
look good you still have to be in shape
i'm not gonna you know discount the the
looks aspect of that he's gotta be six
feet tall he's gotta have a v tape or
he's got to have six-pack abs got that
but he also has to have some kind of
success he has to have achieved
something and it takes longer for men to
mature into their peak potential than it
does for women so women's peak potential
in the sexual marketplace is 23 and for
men it's about 36. now does that mean
that 36 year old guys are banging 23
year old girls absolutely not i'm just
saying that they're mutually exclusive
okay so the 23 year old girl is at the
peak of her potential the guy who's 36
assuming he's made the most of himself
and he's the best version of himself
that he can be it's probably going to
happen right around 36 37 somewhere in
there okay because it takes longer for
him to do so to work his way up that
hierarchy as i was saying as this
happens the problem is that once women
get down to about 30 years old and men
are on their ascension to their peak
that that point right there where and i
called the peak or the uh the ascension
whatever it is the peak potential for
them um that you'll also notice that
that is exactly the year or right around
the year that most men and women get
married when a woman is just on her
declination and the guy is on his ascent
when it comes to sexual market value so
the got and you'll see this is uh
in in the united states it holds true
anyways the
age average age of first marriage in the
united states if for men is about 29 to
30 years old for women about 28 to 29
right exactly as that is is happening
okay it's 31. ever due to first marriage
really am i crazy yeah that's this is so
interesting i didn't know that's why
they say um women wait at the finish
lines and [ __ ] the winners
so basically it's like the epiphany
phase is a girl saying [ __ ] i gotta cash
out soon because my looks are going to
go and i'm not going to have the same
options right so i gotta get married as
quick as i can
that's why i like that i had an older
lady on the show and she said when girls
hit 30 they just marry the first guy
that they're yeah
it's true yeah yeah it's true that's
crazy
um and so what happens is women want to
check out of the sexual marketplace
before they age out and it's that that
expiration date and men they're hoping
that men are going to be stupid enough
to not
to not know that they're going to have
more sexual selectivity when they get to
be 36
36 if they take care of themselves and
also as far as uh reproductive potential
is concerned uh every year after 30 your
chances of having you know successfully
conceiving a child and then having no
complications as a result of that goes
down all the way until you get to b40
and that's why i i
raised bloody hell about this uh what is
it freezing your eggs is some sort of
like benefit for you know what is for
middle management at sea yeah at what
facebook you know uh fortune 500
companies are offering that as benefits
to women who want to pursue their career
it's not interesting it's not about your
career it's the fact that you can't find
the guy that you think you deserve and
so what happens well that's the thing
that fortune 5 workers are offering
their well here you know this is exactly
this is a financial podcast so let let
me explain something to you here you
think that's true partially yeah i think
i think it is i think a lot of women do
focus and it is genuine that they want
to put their career first but i think if
the right man was in front of you no
matter what point in time you are in
your career you would have your child
yeah do you know what i mean that's why
they say abortion is the ultimate form
of hypergamy because it's basically
saying that guy was not the best that i
could do i don't want his offspring
i need to find a better like i mean in
the animal kingdom what they do they
take the mom and they kill the cubs
and like in 2022 that's what they're
doing yeah yeah yeah you think about it
because like they're saying yeah nah not
this guy this isn't the right that's my
whole thing with playing with nature
don't play with what is naturally like
inclined to you right
i've barely been on birth control like
ever i was only on birth control for
like a year in college and i feel like
it's made me make a lot better decisions
because you take what like the
consequence is always there of like
exactly
exactly
and when you take away like i don't know
i'm with you like i don't like messing
with nature and like what's supposed to
happen yeah unless it's like the only
ever the only time i would say that it's
an issue is if you know it comes down to
your health or if it's something that
was um unwanted do you know what i mean
otherwise if it's just you there's
nothing wrong with you you're perfectly
healthy you're fine you know you're in
you might be in a healthy relationship
or you're in a place where you're single
and you're doing what you want to do in
life don't play with nature if things
happen be accountable you're grown
that's absolutely have accountability
and then they'll say oh why does he wrap
it up i'm like well why don't you close
your legs like we could make the same
exactly you can make the same argument
it's just like you don't have to and
like the crazy thing is everyone i know
that's had an abortion like it's always
they're irresponsible yeah i know i know
like two or three girls that have had
them actually and like which fun fact
one out of every girl one out of every
three women that makes over forty seven
thousand dollars per year has had one or
will have one yeah and so it's like it's
a lot of times people make it an income
issue when only eight percent of women
below the property
or below the poverty line get abortions
and i think it's because women that make
more money are around them than they
want but they can't get them so they're
like i can't reproduce with this man
that's crazy yeah and so it's like i'm
just a big believer in like
being accountable like everything in
life's your own fault exactly and you
can either take accountability like even
my mom she got pregnant when she was 17
by my dad and they gave that kid up for
adoption something to you here if you
are investing in in the future and you
want to do so uh based on gender or
based on on on sexual you know trends
right now invest in anything that uh
promotes fear of missing out for women
and anything that promotes the idea that
their sexual market value will be
evergreen
forever so
yeah was it cryogenics for for for ovum
cryogenics that's another one uh
anything uh beauty products right women
don't want to look older they want to
look what younger so it you know the the
the cosmetic industry is not this
multi-trillion dollar juggernaut because
women want to look older it's because
they want to look as if they were 23
years old because that's what men are
looking for they're looking for that
that's what we base our attraction i
have a question are we talking strictly
physical appearance here or sing in
general no because i see this is my
actual serious question if you are
successful entrepreneur ceo whatever
you're smart your lawyer doctor whatever
you are and you're 30 something set
let's say you're 37 and you start dating
a girl who's 22
23 on the peak right
what are you talking to her about
she doesn't have any like you can you
can think she's hot as much as you want
i'm sure she is but what are you that's
not your life partner maybe she is super
mature and maybe you're going to have
something to talk to maybe she's and
this is what she's she's looking at this
from the experience of a woman yeah as a
woman we don't want someone that doesn't
have life experience we don't want we we
don't want that but men would would take
you over her any day 21 year old yeah
because one the older woman comes with
all these expectations right she's
already been wined and died and she's
done everything so it's like you can't
impress her and also men are big kids do
you know what i mean because i feel like
people always say well what do they have
to talk about yeah you have different
lives and different things and whatever
he might be more experienced but men are
actually big kids and when a man likes
you he will show you that side of him
regardless of anything so that's never
going to be enough i don't really like
to talk like that exactly yeah exactly
you don't even like to talk period
that's why you go to your girlfriend
exactly and that's why he has his
boyfriend like his male friend my
ex-boyfriend would always tell me to
shut up exactly that baby talk to me he
would just be
and it's not rude it's just they're like
they they use less words they're
different yeah
and so she's trying to make the men like
women when they're like well what would
you talk to them about because that's
how you would think of an inexperienced
man yeah because we want something to
talk about exactly but that's not that's
not mad they don't care
and they also say like
i mean i have heard guys say they like
older women but it's for a different
reason it's because the older women are
more likely to settle down but if a girl
is in that mindset and 22 they're
picking the 22 year old 100 are you nuts
over at 32 like the reason they don't
like 22 year olds is because all they
want to do is party and like do that
[ __ ] but if you're not doing that
they'll definitely go they're picking
you like yeah 100 100
but when you're looking at this in the
perspective of from a woman
okay but let me let me continue do you
guys want an unintelligent like
why do we why do we presume that a woman
who is 23 year old is not intelligent
enough to get with the guy that's number
one number two
most guy i know most guys at that age
who have that peak sexual selectivity
they're not looking for like for a
long-term partner they're not looking
for at 23 they're looking right around
26 or 27.
okay
i got confused as soon as you cut out um
so i'm just saying i have a lot of
friends who are in their early 20s
you're talking about how the 22 year old
isn't smart no i mean and at your big
age and you're confused
like i i understood perfect yeah yeah
we're younger but that's why i like like
that's why men don't like older women
it's not even necessarily like some look
good and they tell me it's not about the
looks it's like the mindset like a
girl's single too long like she just
it's like me me me me how can you
impress me but they don't bring any
value to the guy they can't cook they
can't clean i was on a podcast with her
and i asked her her boyfriend or
whatever
pays her rent i said what does he get in
return she couldn't name me anything
she's like oh i'm not gonna share that
i'm like outside of sex because he could
have sex with anyone yeah what are you
doing to be a wife yeah yeah yeah how
are you building for your relationship
like what are you giving him yeah you
know what i mean and it's like nothing
oh my gosh
whatever yeah and i when i'm sitting
there me as a 31 year old woman i'm
sitting there i'm like you guys have
like i just can't even sit here anymore
there's nothing to talk about and these
girls are smart they go to nice schools
they come from a good family but their
vision of life and it's just like
there's nothing you can
there's nothing you have in common so
what when you're 23 and you get together
with somebody who's 37 a successful
lawyer and you're just like you got in
your
dreams this is a sorority
like you guys are not on the same i
actually agree with you
and like i understand what she's saying
but she's talking about like in the
party phase yeah like that's what she's
taught i i understand like when i was
when i was i think i stopped drinking at
21 so when i was 19 20 right like i was
drinking all the time and like going out
so like that's a completely different
lifestyle than i do who's 35 wanting to
settle down but if you don't have that
lifestyle like there's no reason for him
to date an older woman yeah and also
like i don't know about you yet but one
of my requirements i would say is that i
would i would love to have or have had a
however man that can teach me things
yeah and that comes with life it's like
i just maybe come teach me about a
little something i want to see her and
learn from my mom like and i think
that's so attractive and i think it's
all about the perspective if if because
hearing i say that in my head the first
thing that came to my head is you're
living in a fairy tale
genuinely yeah
in a little bubble yeah because
you have all these little things that
you think you would want an xy and said
but reality needs to hate you like
that's not how life is
no it's like
you can't tell men like older women and
then think they're gonna it's like yeah
i get it and even i i had a post the
other day where i was saying like you
could shame men but it doesn't change
what they like because they're like you
should want a woman who's educated i'm
like i'm sorry men don't really care
they want you to have common sense yeah
they don't want you to be dumb as rocks
but like sarah huckabee sanders is very
smart but men aren't lining up to date
her same with oprah yeah both very
intelligent women exactly
yeah i asked guys sarah how could you
know sarah huckabee sanders yes her aoc
even though aoc is like crazy to a lot
of these could like conservative men
they're picking aoc because she's high
100
100
and also disagree with you at the same
time and and
we'll we'll kind of bring this defense
there no but i but there
because i'm in that world like
by day i'm
i'm very open about this by day i'm in
the financial world i work for a
financial firm i have to be very
financial but at night i'm in [ __ ]
south beach partying with 20 something
year olds there is a difference but like
i might see a 23 year old and be like
damn she's hot
and then i go to talk to her and i'm
like yeah she's kind of but you're not
going to marry her you're not you're not
interested
so to to both your points you're talking
about almost
sexual market value how they look to an
extent and you're basically saying hey
look
yeah maybe you know 23 years or hotter
but i can guarantee you at 31 i'm
smarter i'm you know savvier i dress
better i look better definitely a little
bit more high maintenance no yeah you
just know but there's that's the whole a
lot more high maintenance you know
because by the time they're older it's
like i have to get my nails done i have
to get my lashes done i have to do all
this stuff when i when i was 20 21 i'm
just like you just take me to chipotle
baby yeah take me to chipotle
it takes me to chick-fil-a
and i am impressed
like oh my god he paid for my nando's
meal yeah yeah like baby and that's like
they don't want these girls that are
like they're not impressed by anything
like it's just a headache to them
because on it because at some point it's
like what can you do
yeah what is he gonna do that's gonna
impress you at that point exactly
and it's like they just they say to men
like me like me like me it's like the
same with the whales
like dude okay do you know how
delusional i would have to be to go to
modeling agencies and say hey i'm a tall
ginger put us on the cover i feel
discriminated against like they would
say i'm narcissistic but plus-sized
women can do that and that's like what
women do is they like they shame men
into like older women they're they're
saying ageism now yeah and it's just a
thing it's not it's not a it's like
it's a thing but it's not it's natural
yeah but yeah you ben should have been
married by now like why why are you 45
at the club they should be
discriminating against you
just like i don't really think most 50
year old men should be at the club
hundred percent yeah yeah your wife and
kids and your grandkids yeah like we're
supposed to have families by now you've
had you've had half the century
men and women like it's been 40. you've
lived half your life where have you been
yeah yeah fully it's free game we're all
in the same boat honey just you better
get your asses married okay
yeah
so um any final thoughts you got on this
video roller's interesting
i'm literally like i've taken a mental
note i'm gonna go and look into him a
little more because i think hmm i i i
see what he's saying yeah i've learned a
lot um maybe i think his approach you
know a lot of men have um have a very
like aggressive blatant straight
approach and i think that's where a lot
of women
can't hear what they're saying no that's
what i say is rollo yeah but i like that
because that's the only way you're going
to get fruit to them
you know what i mean it makes sense to
why well i feel like there's like the
men have the message a lot of times and
then we understand how to communicate it
to women and so a lot of times like
that's what i do on my show is like i'm
saying i always give credit where credit
is due a lot of my ideas come from him
where and like i could say it in like a
softer way yeah you know where girls can
like take that in that's exactly it men
have the message and women are the
communicators it's like like kevin
samuels
women are left over at 35 i'll be like
look oh my god you can't say you're more
attractive at 35 than you were at you
know yeah yeah exactly that's what it is
so tell the people where they can find
you
guys i have a podcast good conscious
conversations it's on youtube spotify
and apple music
it's c.conversations podcast on
instagram and that official mirror on
instagram check me out guys we'll be
seeing pal very soon yeah so um do
subscribe like all that good stuff and
thank you for having me thank you for
coming y'all like this video that is the
most important thing in the algorithm so
make sure you like it sign up for our
memberships if you want to be a part of
the chat during our live shows and you
want to see two behind the scenes vlogs
including me ish and jess going out to a
salsa bar so it's a lot of fun so if you
guys want to see it um subscribe to the
channel bring that notification bell and
we'll talk to you next time